salut romain ça va
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
boire ou conduire
il faut choisir voilà bravo tout le
monde sait ça tous ne le fait pas mais
tout le monde connaît le slogan c'est
déjà ça mais si je vous dis fumée ou
conduire fumer un joint ou conduire
est-ce qu'il faut choisir attention
c'est illégal 1 bien sûr là je parle
juste d'un point de vue physiologique
et du coup oui fumée ou conduire il faut
choisir
bon ok on va développer un peu ça
m'arrange pas parce que j'ai rendez vous
pour un soin du visage là je alors déjà
il faut savoir que de la même manière
qu'il ya des alcootests il ya aussi des
tests pour vérifier si on a consommé du
cannabis avant de conduire que ça c'est
un délit et qui dit délits dits sanction
mais c'est pas tellement ça qui nous
intéresse nous on va s'intéresser aux
pourquoi
pourquoi la consommation de cannabis est
pas compatible avec la conduite alors si
on jette un petit coup d'oeil aux
chiffres qu'est ce qu'on voit ça on voit
que dans un accident mortel sur cinq
l'un des conducteurs est positif aux
stupéfiants que ça passe à 1 sur 3 la
nuit et les week-ends et que c'est du
cannabis dans l'immense majorité des cas
voilà attention ça veut pas dire que les
stupéfiants sont le seul facteur
responsable c'est un peu plus complexe
que ça et ça veut encore moins dire que
la majorité des accidents est causée par
des gens qui n'ont rien pris donc c'est
moins dangereux de conduire défoncé fait
pas les malins un autre chiffre pour
mettre tout le monde d'accord sachez
qu'on estime que le cannabis multiplie
par 1,65 le risque d'être responsable
d'un accident mortel
bon c'est vrai qu'une fois qu'on a dit
ça on n'a pas dit grand chose finalement
ok on va développer encore mais vraiment
après tout que je suis ferme ensemble
parce que avec l'automne c'est plus
possible regardez je suis tout étiolé
les chiffres c'est bien gentil mais
c'est pas tellement que ça qu'on parle
ici donc on va essayer de répondre à la
question autrement en gros on va voir ce
qui se passe dans notre corps quand on
consomme du cannabis et voir si c'est
compatible avec la conduite même si j'ai
déjà ce pôle est la réponse à cette
question c'est non pour comprendre
comment ça marche on va partir de la
base le cannabis c'est quoi c'est un
même mot qui désigne à la fois une
plante et le produit stupéfiant qu'on
fabrique avec
sous différentes formes et c'est pas
tellement le sujet nous ce qui nous
intéresse c'est de comprendre comment il
agit sur notre organisme le cannabis qui
contient plus de 550 composés organiques
dont plus d'une centaine de phyto
cannabinoïdes et parmi ces fit aux
cannabinoïdes y en a trois qui sont un
peu particulier le canadien paul qu'on a
appelée cbn le cannabis violent appelons
le cbd connaissez sûrement on en
reparlera ici un de ces jours et le
delta 9 t3 hydro cannabinol le thc et
c'est à lui qu'on va s'intéresser parce
que c'est au thc qu'on doit les
principaux effets psychoactifs du
cannabis c'est à dire les effets sur le
système nerveux central ou le cerveau et
donc sur nos perceptions nos émotions et
notre comportement le cbn il en a dix
fois moins que le thc et le cbd il en a
pas du tout donc restons sur le thc
petit truc quand même pour les gens qui
prennent du cbd il peut contenir un peu
de thc pas assez pour que ça ait des
effets psychoactifs mais si on vous fait
un test il peut potentiellement être
positif c'est bon à savoir mais bon le
thc donc quand on consomme du cannabis
sous n'importe quelle forme le taux de
thc il augmente dans notre organisme et
vous vous doutez bien qu'il va pas
rester à rien faire il va chercher un
endroit où se poser et de quoi s'occuper
le thc c'est une substance de la famille
des cannabinoïdes on avait déjà parlé
ici et les cannabinoïdes on en fabrique
nous mêmes notre organisme sécrète des
andes aux cannabinoïdes c'est à dire
littéralement décanat been qu'ils
viennent de l'intérieur comme les
endorphines c'est de la morphine vient
de l'intérieur donc oui on produit notre
propre drogue mais celle là elle est
légale c'est endocannabinoïdes c'est des
neurotransmetteurs c'est à dire des
substances chimiques qui sont produites
par nos neurones qui vont se fixer sur
des récepteurs bien spécifique pour
faire passer un message dans notre
système nerveux et déclenché une
réaction bien précises essai
endocannabinoïdes il se fixe
essentiellement sur deux types de
récepteurs laisser b1 qui se trouvent
dans notre cerveau et les cb2 sur les
cellules du système immunitaire comme
lara tous les amygdales donc on va se
pencher sur les premiers parce que vous
vous doutez bien que ce qui nous
intéresse c'est par là que ça se passe
laissez bien il déclenche des actions à
plusieurs niveaux et l'autre book de thc
là quand il est en goguette dans notre
organisme il finit par tomber dessus on
se balade et comme lui aussi c'est un
cannabinoïde il se dit
donc il se fixe sur les récepteurs mais
comme son taux est beaucoup plus élevé
que celui des endocannabinoïdes que les
c b1 sont habitués à recevoir c'est un
peu la panique là dedans ça perturbe le
message donc les fonctions concernées
mais alors de quoi on parle exactement
ces récepteurs sur quoi ils agissent
quand ils sont stimulés déjà ils jouent
un rôle dans la libération de la
dopamine vous savez l'hormone
vraiment une hormone dont on a déjà
parlé alors vous allez me dire ok mais
ça ça empêche pas conduire je vois ce
que vous voulez me dire sauf que c'est
précisément ce qui provoque cette
ivresse caractéristique est la
somnolence qui va avec ça nous donne un
premier élément de réponse à notre
question parce que bon conduire en état
d'ivresse peu importe ce qui nous a mis
dans cet état là c'est pas ouf on le
sait ensuite ils agissent au niveau du
système limbique qui est responsable de
la régulation de nos émotions et du
cortex et de l'hippocampe qui sont le
siège de la mémoire là encore peut-être
que vous vous dites que ça va ça passe
mais si on y regarde de plus près c'est
vrai que les effets sur la mémoire il
arrive au bout d'un certain temps de
consommation mais dans un premier temps
ça joue aussi sur la tension est là on
voit bien que conduire en ayant du mal à
se concentrer sur la route c'est pas une
bonne idée
d'autant plus qu'en agissant aussi sur
le système de régulation de nos émotions
le thc y perturbe notre capacité à
prendre des décisions adaptées et il
peut modifier notre comportement
habituel en nous rendre en plus impulsif
et moins réfléchie par exemple et là
encore c'est des choses qui sont très
peu compatible avec la conduite
mais surtout nos fameux récepteur cb1 y
déclenche des réactions au niveau du
cervelet qui s'occupe de la motricité et
de la coordination des mouvements et du
thalamus qui est chargée des perceptions
sensorielles comme la vue et l'audition
par exemple bon les conséquences sur la
conduite elles sont assez faciles à
imaginer un ralentissement général des
mouvements moins bien coordonnée des
réflexes moins vif et quand je parle de
réflexe je parle pas des trucs que le
médecin vous fait faire avec son petit
marteau
je parle de temps de réaction et de
décisions rapides genre 1 ça freine
devant moi je serai aussi
je pense que vous est ce que je veux
dire s'il ya ça vous ajoutez le fait que
ça augmente notre sensibilité aux sons
que ça provoque une distorsion de notre
champ de vision est que ça peut aller
jusqu'à des forme d'hallucination
visuelle et auditive je sais pas ce que
vous en pensez mais bon c'est non et
comme en plus le cannabis perturbe notre
perception du temps et de l'espace
notamment en terme de distance vous
imaginez les répercussions que cela peut
avoir en termes d'allongement des
distances de freinage ou de contrôle des
trajectoires par exemple donc on résume
en agissant sur toutes ses zones de
notre cerveau et de notre système
nerveux central le thc y provoque
ivresse somnolence baisse de l'attention
et de la concentration modification du
comportement ralentissement des
mouvements avec diminution des réflexes
modification de la perception de
l'espace et du temps perturbations de
l'ouïe et de la vue voire hallucinations
visuelles et auditives voilà je pense
qu'on est d'accord que si on additionne
tous ses effets le cannabis passe pas le
test de conduite c'est non donc en fait
c'est hyper simple c'est comme pour
l'alcool si on a consommé ont conduit
pas alors je vois venir la question
pendant combien de temps on doit pas
conduire oui je sens bien que vous avez
envie de me demander ça par pure
curiosité scientifique évidemment on
sait que quand il est inhalé
c'est-à-dire fumée le cannabis à des
effets qui atteignent leur maximum au
bout d'une demi heure et que s'il est
ingéré c'est à dire si on le mange le
pic max arrive deux heures après en
vient ensuite ça diminue mais là c'est
plus compliqué on dit que les effets
s'estompent à peu près deux heures et
demie après le dernier juin et environ
sept heures après la dernière bouchée de
space cake mais en vrai c'est pas si
simple ça dépend de plein de choses
comme la quantité de ce qui a été
consommé déjà et une étude menée sur des
pilotes de ligne dans des simulateurs de
vol a montré que certains d'entre eux
continuer à faire deux grossières
erreurs de pilotage jusqu'à 24 heures
après avoir fumé un jour oui ils ont
fait fumer des joints à des pilotes de
l'est
mais c'est pour la science alors ça va
pour être complet sur la question il ya
deux petites choses que je voudrais
ajouter avant d'aller faire mention du
visage d'abord là on n'a parlé que du
cannabis parce que c'est ce qui est le
plus consommé mais évidemment vu que le
principe d'une drogue c'est précisément
d'avoir des effets psychoactifs ont
rappelé dans a parlé tout à l'heure bah
elles ont toutes des conséquences sur la
façon de conduire de ce qu'on consomme
des conséquences négatives 1 les
discours du genre en une en mai mois
dans ces cas là je conduis mieux en
faites pas ce que je fais plus gaffe
désolé mais c'est non vous avez
l'impression de faire plus gaffe mais en
fait vous êtes moins efficace donc vous
conduisez moins bien et pour boucler la
boucle avec cette histoire de boire ou
conduire un petit mot sur l'alcool les
effets du cannabis et de l'alcool il se
potentialisent c'est à dire que quand on
consomme les deux les effets ils
s'additionnent pas ils se multiplient et
avec les autres drogues c'est pas mieux
on estime que si on mélange alcool et
drogue on multiplie par 29 le risque
d'avoir un accident mortel s'est
beaucoup comme d'hab vous avez les infos
maintenant vous pouvez agir en toute
connaissance de cause voilà dtc c'est
fini pour aujourd'hui on se retrouve
très vite pour de nouvelles vidéos d'ici
là prenez soin de vous et prenez soin
des autres mettez vous bien et surtout
portez vous bien
oui oui j'arrête tout de suite non non
je suis désolé c'est à cause du cannabis
j'attends c'est pas la peine de rester
là vous pouvez non traces ou pas vous
pas vous à 6,6 à s'ils font prendre
maintenant à 6,6 parce que là c'est plus
possible je suis je suis tout étiolé
voilà
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]